all right up next is cars gonna be
Jillian Jillian's in Iowa hi Jillian how
are you I'm great how are you better
than I deserve what's up hey so um need
some encouragement today my husband I
celebrated our anniversary last night
which is awesome and we watched baby
sets to for SVU and it was really
exciting we ended up paying off five
thousand dollars in student loans we
have a lot of student loans though my
husband is in chiropractic school or now
he's graduating in February he and I are
going to have $135,000 of debt once he
graduates and we have $14,000 of a car
loan when he graduates so we have a huge
move coming up we are moving to Hawaii
he got a really amazing job here really
my husband as a chiropractor as a
chiropractor yeah well he'd be making it
his amazing job $7,000 a month seven a
month $7,000 a month yeah okay which I
feel like it's pretty good her
chiropractor for like what we've talked
about with our friends you heard some
other people no station and then I yeah
yeah and then um I am blessed enough to
stay with my company I work in sales
I'll be doing a different job though I
don't know exactly what I'm gonna be
making yet right now I make about
$90,000 a year um so we're gonna bring
out a pretty big shovel but we have a
lot of debt and I know Hawaii's gonna be
really expensive like you have an Iowa
right now so living expenses I were
expecting double I don't think it's
quite double but the County Housing and
all it might be not count oh yeah the
other stuff won't be double but housing
might be okay yeah yeah um so I guess I
did the encouragement you know we have
currently guards we got our emergency
fund they're like our one thousand
dollars saved up but we also have twenty
nine thousand dollars in the bank and I
guess what I'm wondering is how much do
we stay for the giant moves across the
ocean
how much should we throw at this debt
which is really freaking me out like
they not have interest is just so scary
I always think about borrowed feature
first episode and it's just like oh my
god listen you're gonna be making look
let's let's talk post move for a minute
after the move you're gonna be sitting
there you should be making 178 years
sounds like mm-hmm so let's pretend you
lived on 70 you'd be debt-free in
eighteen months really well divide your
debt by a hundred thousand a year
you got a hundred thirty-five you told
me right yeah fourteen thousand autocar
right mm-hmm not one hundred and fifty
if you put a hundred on it a year that's
eighteen months and that's you living on
seventy thousand what you can do in
Hawaii mm-hmm I mean that's not just
living like regular people
the average household income in America
is fifty nine thousand so um you know
you can do this you should be done in
eighteen months after you make the move
now the trick to the move is don't pay
more than something's worth to move it
across the ocean so I'm not sure you
even keep your stupid car yeah sell it
and buy another one over there yeah rice
shipping it if you want to price it but
don't pay you $5,000 to ship a four
thousand dollar car you know I mean
that's what you've got to look at and
that couch you got right now it ain't
going with you kiddo you say Oh Thomas
Oh your move what is your move it's a
couple airline tickets yeah we're
playing on checking bags of stuff like
there's certain stuff we don't want to
sell I know but you see what I'm saying
your your move is not gonna be $29,000
your moves a couple of airline tickets
plus or minus a couple thousand bucks
and then you got to get set up in the
new place with some used furniture
from the consignment store in the garage
sale and some basic and you got to put
down your deposits on your utilities and
get into the apartment right and you
rent something as cheap as you can find
because you are deeply in debt yeah okay
can you get yourself out of debt and
then you start talking but don't go rent
a nice place okay you're broke yeah
broke people should recognize places
yeah so you're gonna do you're gonna do
great you're gonna be awesome and so
it's okay why don't we just leave that
twins the move March okay let's just
leave the 29000 order you get moved okay
and put everything else you can scrape
together on the debt between now and
then because we know that 29,000 I'll
buy you a couple airline tickets and get
a few other bags of stuff over there
right yeah and we know we can get you in
an apartment and get your utilities set
up for under that and so you should have
20 grand plus left when you get there to
throw it to that when you get settled in
yeah if we budget nine thousand for the
move and you know buying a used couch at
a garage sale after you get there mm-hmm
and just can't camp for eighteen months
after you get there in a sense right yes
I got caught broke college students you
know concrete blocks to build shelves
for your books and all that kind of crap
like your college students go buy a bean
bag or something right and yeah all
right that's kind of you know I'm
talking about justjust beasts go on the
cheap for eighteen months make a hundred
and seventy put a hundred on the debt
and you're debt-free okay
touchdown baby touchdown right and you
call me from what switch island are you
going to on Hawaii on Oahu ah so wheat
yeah you're gonna love it
it's beautiful there